only et got a glimpse of the North
Carolina mansion fit for a racing wife
oh it's the house that masks our bills
yes please
15,000 square feet five bedrooms eight
baths
that's what five point six million
dollars will get you in North Carolina
along with a private dock on Lake Norman
it's a perfect home for a NASCAR driver
Kurt Busch and his polo-playing bride
Ashley she once crossed Mallett's with
Prince Harry pressure where you're
thinking okay I can't accidentally hit
or hurt the Prince or something like
that no I think he wants to be played
against like a normal person and a fair
game yeah NASCAR drivers make Bank
Kurt's brother Kyle made an estimated
17.5 mil last year alone check out his
mansion the 7.5 million dollar 10,000
square-foot Tudor has six bedrooms and
eight baths stunning views of the lake a
pool and playground for four-year-old
son Braxton the mansion also doubles as
one of the settings for the Busch
brothers reality series racing lives
here's the thing reality TV can like
make you look at your relationship
differently you always have a camera on
your face so for example you know when
you don't wear sunglasses outside I'm so
squinting and so it looks like I'm
glaring at everybody else I got kind of
like why are you so manic I wasn't mad
at all I just really can't see see I
live a reality show every single weekend
anyways I'm on TV going to the races and
losing and being mad or upset or
whatever and they're like oh he's an SS
you know so it's like we're smelling SS
this man has it for ya
you
[Music]